welcome to this video yeah for some
change of content I'm doing our kibbutz
video again and of course it's just a
matter of luck what players you might
catch playing on the ICC here we have
from playing us black gram master Luke
from Valley the Dutch number I think
it's the number two at the moment
because I'm just curious the Dutch
number one nowadays but if nvd really
has been the Dutchman of the ones I like
reason hey just before that yeah we saw
them the rest of this game where he had
one piece and winning a relatively
easily this game um it is I think the
first game that he is playing at I hope
it's going to be a bit of a longer
session um do have follow-on yeah I have
follow-on so we will follow his games
let's see fan very playing d4 he's a
long time one default player only once
in a while varying we see 493 rarely
plays before so we have on the the
result opening now even transposing to
the French defence the McCutcheon
variation very sharp line with Bishop e2
takes on see 394 and Quincy for this is
the way it is played okay Bishop d2s sir
not so dangerous in comparison the Queen
really should go to g4 to provoke some
weakness
here we have a position where black has
some relatively good chances due to the
pawn structure he's got some weak parts
to play against I cannot during kibbutz
in use the arrows and colors we can
point with the mouse at the square some
talking about like d 4 C 5 c 3 they are
the weaknesses and yeah black can castle
short there is no direct attack yeah
it's not so clear how white should
proceed black hair son now that's
interesting I I guess I would have just
played 96cm but 97 as an interesting
move it maybe intends to get the night
to see four to A for attacking the ponds
or it could also be M the start of a
defensive maneuver just putting the
night let's say on f8 yeah it seems that
this is in fact blacks plane no it's
something different entirely f6 I didn't
really think about but because I think
that this just weakens the upon of
course f6 is the normal plan in the
French but really here the bishop is no
bad on a6 it he wants to play rook a 28
so am I understand the idea of visual
basics I don't really like I don't
really like that f6 plan y term ideally
would like to regroup the bishop to h3
exactly g3 bishop f12 h3 this would be a
very nice for white but not so easy to
accomplish another plan might be night
h4 g2f
for so also possible yeah he probably
wants to regroup okay hmm difficult this
I didn't really expect I thought that
this might might help like this is 95 95
plan yeah the bishop on c8 is not
exactly great but this might change
black cam is may be able to regroup it
like on d 78 and so on but when velius
quickly advancing on the kingside
probably king h1 it's not so easy to get
f5 player into plane
yeah f4 is not not a strong point of
whites game at the moment and now now h5
is a bit weak maybe white can try to
attack it with Queen g32 edge form okay
very tricky position black might play
Queen f7 and a Tekkit one more time ok
white is going to cover with with King
g3 that's a good idea probably getting
the King involved yeah this position is
very closed I mean if you just imagine
what what can why do you can maybe get a
bishop to age three but even then if he
captures on f5 where exactly is widely
going to infiltrate black can just stay
put here ok he does not need to but he
could have easily sacrificed the
exchange I think I would have done that
white has no way forward whatsoever I
mean ok here i don't really see a way
forward as well but still f5 here maybe
then he's six it's probably not really
great
so we went for it white is really
pushing hard now okay the ideas
infiltration of course rookie too I
guess oh the king yeah yeah white white
enters on with the king but how do you
actually make progress I don't see it
Jack Black was playing really quickly
that's helpful now been really down to
44 seconds but um yeah Black is still a
bit tied down it's not so sad evident
how he should win
route d7 yeah it's not clear to me how
black should proceed to candy this can
easily backfire King a six now this
bishop CA check so it's a tactical cover
maybe black can try something like d4 or
before kind of yeah this kind of porn
break its can but it's not really well
supported now that's very very
aggressively played as black maybe
that's really good rook be a check
probably and King c5 Roxy a check so you
get the C porn further advanced and
black also has an F pawn very sharp
position check
ok yeah that's it's now very touchy 7
check is threatened white is pretty
active here is always Roxy 7 I know it
no Roxy saying and King moves and then
probably deform pushing pushing the porn
yeah I guess this is about equal because
of the activity but of course white has
got 10 seconds we are very nicely played
I guess white has defended as well
actively it's just a matter of time now
five seconds white will probably lose on
time unless black is allowing some sort
of made through gate now was winning but
ok why does got no time at all like four
days yeah white is completely winning
now yeah this type of game is one
argument for increments times it's
simply a great fight they it was a
back-and-forth white and if it was a 332
game with two a second incremental once
again to the game is just continuing and
producing interesting content and now it
is just ended because wise overstepped
the time of course this is a traditional
time control but it's just more
interesting from a chess Content
perspective to have those games
continued I'm very interesting play
though let's see let's hope we get some
some more games this was very
interesting if when we should decide to
leave the server i can try to catch some
other interesting grandmaster game
there are some GMS online so um it's
it's possible to get more content um I
don't I don't want to switch down now
because then you get all this kind of
fragmented games always getting right
into the into the middle and then back
and forth I just want to give him a
couple of just one minute or so to start
a new game here we go against ours of
course he's a cool learn it so cool in
young I have played them a couple of
times four and a half out of eight is
Moscow so let's see if when VDS doing
better okay again the the virus off this
kind of line with Bishop f4 somehow
gaining in popularity it has been played
a number of times recently okay probably
not exactly M represents a refutation of
the black opening but it's a gap change
of pace something something else and
then blitz um you can experiment of
course okay quick h3 and g4 yeah Bishop
g6 is strange white wants to play 95 d5
anyway yeah f3 and probably then h4 idea
to play h5 okay just took it it's also
interesting
maybe c3 and tending queen bee three but
okay if I it's not exactly strong but
just try to win this pawn with them
further c3 Quincy 2nite see 42 and then
it's gone yes III looks so good yeah all
that one I was just thinking or queen a
form Queen a fourth no goodness after
Queen fo I think he jack black needed to
move further king okay something else
entirely
that really a weird position with the
King only tool i was trying to to get
some grips on that to check try to
understand it now he is giving the check
yeah i think instead of clearly through
the the immediate check really was
better and maybe rook t4 even rock
deform intending rook t6 and if Bishop
b5 there should be 525 there's rook da
check okay didn't go for that he was
considering it i think yeah black
spoiler castling right Sam it's not
exactly you're helping yeah 02 III
that's interesting g3 looked very normal
to me but maybe he wants to have the
bishop on III to support h4 later it's
possible
yeah still like YTM white has more
pieces in play I mean the King position
is a bit weird but other than that the
rocks rd 1 and C 1 Bishop Pam and
generally active position yeah Black is
grabbing this pawn but after you know
maybe you can do that Bishop g4 maybe
Queen f4 try to try to defend
yeah it looks nice the special bond
before but there is no at least I don't
see a particularly dangerous threat if
you go Bishop e3 here black yeah maybe
like an even play play age 5 or
something like that I b7 Hanks I don't
know if you need to need to cover it
that's interesting as well just
intending to to go to d3 now 93 there is
maybe Bishop f6
93 not sure we should have six king a
queen f6 still this threat on f2 maybe
Queenie for now we gently do that yeah
this is this now look so great for black
isn't it doesn't it isn't it or doesn't
it yeah well black is fine no matter no
matter what hmm yeah white has a very
strong Bishop there on c3 at so let me
do a porn can't hear it's it's just a
just and exchange yeah but how do you
how do you I am maybe this way trying to
get rid of this pin like Bishop d 297
but Dwight has three against one on the
queenside and the bishop pair to support
the pawns the bishop pair is notoriously
great in supporting passes so um maybe
this is still quite um quite a viable
position for for white just like taking
king e to bishops III and then push the
pawns yeah that's not easy that's not so
easy at all or even before just be for
c5 the the night at the moment is really
dominated by the f3 bishop and blacks
king is not not helping only question is
I think bishops III first might be an
ADM you know just
you should Bishop c3 again so that after
four you can capture yeah and now
probably King III and Bishop b2 and then
push all this one yeah this is probably
I'm sorry probably even better just
going for b5 b6 and so on yeah I think
black is lost him to be honest this was
very tricky I guess black head of a good
position certainly he when when he went
when he got to the three but this end
game on was very problematic and not not
easy to play at all yeah just be five
passports must be pushed that's really
true sorry I'm a bit of a sore throat
here jump Bishop maybe we should be for
first and yeah but ok it's it's a queen
it's not okay you've got the a pond
without the a pawn this is so not not so
clear actually but this should be a
relatively easy win yeah well what this
is Larry Christian Shin Christensen's
Blitzer motto you never resign when you
still have a night left and black has
one so you can strive for tricks here
now black has got a little counter play
but the a porn is probably too strong
canyon somewhere yeah and then push the
pawn just a 7 yeah should be gone 19
seconds against 19 seconds Jack the RF
is not so quick here yet Lucas just
hanging check now why is really playing
slowly maybe it's got some some
technical problem Queenie original a
jade is made into you check checkmate no
I hope the recordings fine i just had to
screw the screensaver coming up very
strange on ok so he managed to to mate
with two seconds left on the clock um if
i guess around here jack like a suddenly
in great shape but he needs to probably
you need to get the needs to keep the
quiz on like I think maybe what did you
replace this maybe t2 I don't really
know how to maybe I can do an exam in
here and then no I cannot I screw this
up I thought I could maybe a get in to
examine wrote in this game alright we
have a new game this is more interesting
and let's make sure that son following
okay we've got a repels defense yeah
interesting it's not an opening that he
plays regularly but okay
it's blitz chess yeah the opponent is
playing a modern set up against them I
would a 4 yeah that's that's not that's
not so common nowadays so why does
playing in a very positional strategical
fashion now probably young Bishop c4 and
he's got a very solid position h3
covering G for a five winning space on
the queenside now e4 is attacked okay so
why it is agreeing to to surrendering
the bishop our bishop h5 would have had
a g5 and denied you form so black has
got the two bishops which is very nice
in this position no no that is now he's
got the perfect Bishop out ya know b5
and it's very nice for black he's got
two bishops against two nights and
possibilities like who in before yeah
pressurizing the b2 pond and there's
also this some despot on a six which is
a potential weakness let's see what what
could like do I mean there are many
possible ideas the a7 porn however
something to to look at Luke t8 I
thought white should maybe Jake I don't
know g4 really
yeah yeah this I saw as well I'm not
sure what it is doing probably it just
blocks the view towards they seven pawn
of course 90 for ED forum black is going
to take on c3 at the end this is nice
Andrew Cardiff is also not on yeah
that's maybe a good move really
night-night a two could be a good beer
could be in response but then black can
take on d1 play Queen a three-win day 6
pawn okay tricky yeah this this sent
white into some some some thought well
this is just is just flat-out losing i
guess i don't know i mean black i didn't
think like a really threaten something
super-dangerous and this is clearly lost
just just take on c3 and you've got two
bishops for the rook and white as
weakened himself with g4 enormously
check yeah I'm Bishop e7 yeah g5 is not
bad as long to d2 to see three black ass
got them three points here that you can
push just c5 here I guess yeah okay this
is this is also good yeah this is
relatively easy to play Queen Bishop e7
maybe grabbing before
yeah there are so many weaknesses here
besides the fact that the two bishops
are just stronger than the look anyway
but why does some so weakened King side
plus the DD the deep on now probably
just Bishop c4 and then you can can try
to to get to the a pawn rook c8 see 6
a-6 nothing that white can do against it
yeah look a father's we should be three
even yeah Bishop e3 is coming yeah I
guess it's time for the Sun this button
the button to press yeah oh please don't
let the clock run down just be glad that
you're playing a good GM or played
resign hello eerie signs okay yeah this
was a pretty one side of the fam around
here I guess I guess white needs to play
a 92 here I cannot put it on the board
to cover you for the way it went down
here I mean this is already very
comfortable and and here he decided to
give up the second bishop as well and
well here black is an excellent shape
it's just a great long-term acid and
this is not helping a six because of b5
yeah yep like is substantially better
I'm really surprised that in this
position if you go here Queenie 3 the
stock fish engine that I have here the
latest version assess is this position
is equal which is frankly a joke I mean
with them with the two bishops like a
substantially better long-term it's not
so evident at the moment because it's a
symmetrical position which is fairly
closed but um it's it's simply a
long-term asset and it's not easily
equal equalized against in the long run
okay so let's hope for the new game soon
I don't as mentioned to want to want to
switch so much and
get those game fragments going it's
possible that he has requested a new
five-minute game but it sometimes takes
a while when I do the video 7 I record I
quite often hit the five-minute a button
here and it takes 20 seconds 30 seconds
to get a game the depends obviously how
much traffic there is on the server yeah
let's hope we get a new game soon well
while I'm at it I can mention that the
candidates tournament for the World
Championship challenger is not not far
away it's just not what is it 10 11 days
March thirteenth it's the first round
and obviously one of them highlights of
the year we had a very exciting
candidates tournament last year in
London where was some glad enough to
have the chance to visit it this time
it's in in Siberia in Russia and no way
that I'm going to visit that I actually
checked this how would you get down it's
a it's terribly expensive and a bit too
adventure adventurous for my taste
besides the fact that when you are in
counting on disk you can watch this
tournament but besides that there's
relatively little things to do maybe
correct me if you are from the earth but
I didn't didn't seem so attractive to me
so I didn't follow that and I also have
league games coming up yeah there's no
game starting um yeah of course I will
cover the the candidates tournament
doing
daily coverage it's again in 8-player
double round-robin tournament so we have
four games daily and it's been a very
fighting tournament last year so really
looking forward to that let's um let's
see how this is going to to end who will
challenge magnus carlsen at the end of
the year yeah I don't get a game of
their slow game starting here let's see
what kind of games do we have who else
is playing we can the meantime have a
look at Yardbird grandma sierra club on
regular opponent in my my videos he's
playing a black here against then feed
master called [ __ ] cameroon no chance
our town can live in istanbul turkey
yeah below the flag maybe he's there on
vacation or something you don't know ok
um so what kind of position is this we
have equal material and this has some
come up out of a coke on defense i guess
some young is this abominable yeah Black
has the bishop which sometimes gives
gives an edge long-range peace but the
pawn structure is not so brilliant yeah
probably this is about equal ok as usual
Yardbird LeBron is playing ambitiously
don't really know if this is so
right yeah maybe even wondering about 91
but yeah night 91 III f5 would be nice
but not easy to accomplish 91 probably
whip c1 and black invades yeah he has
played this very ambitious Lee but not
badly I guess it look so looks like
white is under some pressure i'm not
mistaken yeah whoopsie one it looks so
it looks a bit tricky for me tricky to
me tricky for white I mean it's not not
so easy to play this position the rook
is invading f3s possible weakness maybe
the checks now I'm unknown yeah night I
said now you can play 97 rooks is
selling rookie one yeah that's that's
strong actually if black now plays king
d 6 you just can't go back or this one
interesting I I think he has overlooked
that there's roots III mate threatened
funny King yet now so black has one
changes that's a funny funny trick by
the way that fun Bailey has disconnected
so we only played three games
unfortunately so let's see maybe em get
get one or two game some
here play by am a noob run by output and
then wrap this video up yeah Black has a
piss-up this is Bishop and he now some I
think managing to get the f6 porn which
was the source of counter play yeah I
instilled as a and B porn I mean blitz
um it's it's still some counter play
it's not enough but it's something that
you first need to kill off before you
can be sure to win Luke um maybe rook c6
to c3 something like that now okay 50
does this that's two pawns and now maybe
before b4 b5 check how that that should
be an easy win I'm not sure about that
really the thing is this also the wrong
colored bishop let's get not not a g5g
five now white sg5 and the h-bond
promotes I think he's not playing that
yeah that's it simply again Dwight
Dwight is probably thinking okay I'm
winning on time anyway so on does not
need to play good moves now we push the
pawn but is this winning now
probably not Bishop c3 back hmm maybe
this could be a draw actually I know
Bishop f5 was possible yeah white can
just stay put Kimmy 45 but he will win
on time some black forfeits one time
yeah so this position was almost
completely dead of course but gap in
some the time d decides white had some
chances to I believe to win the game
with the g5 earlier not sure if I get
this I need to make this ok I'm around
here and get got here and here g5
exactly here it is strong i think
because the the bishop might relocate to
to e5 but then you have those pawns
marching as well that's probably too
much it's very very dangerous probably
winning i can switch on the engine to to
check this yeah adds plots plus 12 plus
12 so there will there will be a
promotion ok um it's not playing playing
a new game okay we've got yessir Sarah
one online just locked on maybe is
playing a couple of games would be nice
to have fun yeah so playing always a joy
to watch him play it's a really great
strategical player and really trying to
play good news
um you're going for any yeah let's say
fishy blitz play it's not you can play
all kinds of styles and blitz but he
really tries to play a play good chess
yeah it's not starting again would be
nice LeBron also not starting a game
they don't want to switch again I keep
an eye on those two guys someone else
now let's give them with two possible
player so to start a game one of them
will start again I have a couple of more
grand masters online but they don't want
to switch again
okay let's check if there's something
that we can look at while we okay so
LeBron has logged off so maybe we have
more lucky with so the SL
ok ok I'm rust or maybe this one maybe
this guy can have a look here this is I
keep an eye on on Sarah wanna like to
keep its him a bit that I started
another game to follow this is a three
minute game actually YT a key bak in
1987 this is bak keep redoing a witch if
i'm pronouncing this correctly baki
puedo image from from bosnia bosnia and
herzegovina am very strong Graham master
rated above 2600 and he's a good three
minute player 25 is a very high rating
in three minute poor the ratings are
usually a bit lower than in five minute
because this is somewhat younger pool it
is less inflated okay I'm a very strange
position why this 35 why does support
down and then some trouble I guess the
thing like it's nicely centralized and
then no name for the black player but
it's a very murky position maybe just 94
ja all kinds of things might happen dear
boy yes blundered on a three this was
really a probably really a blunder black
hamper now just to treat the night the
bishop here here for example my black as
an exchange up and probably probably
winning but still it needs to be back
and he's finished off or just this is a
funky trick wow now queen before
threatened oh this is tough yeah i think
the d7 rook must move now other
otherwise is probably a mate we be
formed I know the rook no you need to
move look I think look be one maybe I is
just pushing the hat on can kids it's
very little time like it's only seven
seconds left oh wow but that's probably
a win for black isn't it rookie one
double shifts it's a threat but he's got
two seconds only two seconds left check
jacket black forfeit on time yeah began
a time when we're white is completely
lost um yeah he are but he really hot
you really have much here this this was
really cared check
check this mean weather is very strong
suddenly initiating this counter play
maybe i don't know i mean it's it's
tough to tough to her to analyze maybe a
move like rooks III here that's
interesting just cover III for the
moment okay a new three minute game by
brothers player comic-con advance yeah
c5 that's an interesting way to play it
some less explored compared to Bishop f5
but leading to interesting play there
should be three now normally no is
giving it away mc5 white normally tries
to keep it for a moment this pawn on c5
or deform a bee or a five and then G
form yeah Black has a good Bishop now on
c6 that's that's clear hmm but still
mhm tough too tough to judge what is
this jang jin then 93 yeah black thought
he has some compensation but easily
enough be five maybe okay but i can't
take on f3 and on c5 is probably ok but
a 3 is also not not easy yeah very
quickly played it takes p form just
banking on the fact that night f7 is
probably not good king 8 9 h8 and takes
on c3 this is probably not grateful
because of this offside night like look
maybe can take it and play B 3 B 3 as a
threat now i guess and oak GA what is
the part of oak GA well that's a bizarre
move hard to tell I don't really know I
don't know what what this was all about
you know white will just take up someone
I mean added I don't understand anything
of that it's a very very tricky to stuff
maybe night f7 night h6o trying to
provoke why to take yeah I feel that
black is probably a probably okay
because of this exceptionally strong
bishop on d5 on now maybe f 6m yeah I
think white should have taken really 107
this is this is helpful for black
Hammond he had exactly six covered now
with the bishop on d5 yeah maybe here
just take it only five I mean okay
now what for the top position the rook
on a2 is nicely placed like the
effective piece they are proving it just
want to take it seems I know it does
take white has a definite play against
the the beach and bond may be 94 93
something like that yeah yeah black is a
pawn up with white really has some
activity so the time is some about equal
oh it will be 10 now it's not equal why
does better should be seven now Bishop
b5 there should be five is strong move
intending would be 80 the I'd still
strong Brooks his heaven now threatened
and rugby 8 threatened winnings g8 maybe
gang yeah Andrew k800 bb7 wow I'm amazed
that black is still on the board very
strong defense don't know the time is so
again deciding this game you lack for
effect on town yeah white was just pre
moving quicker at the end but he had the
better position at the end with the
active rooks I mean I'm not sure about
the the final position on but um when we
look at this white was obviously
pressing and had a very very good
position but somehow black was not
falling apart it really looks like this
should happen but this configuration
would be 597 496 is pretty resilient not
easily easily taken down so quite
surprising okay I was checking here but
um Sarah Juan is not not playing and he
even left the server so I'm going to
wrap up this video
I've caught about 55 minutes of
Grandmaster blitz chess I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching